now what I love about this one and what  I love about peeps in this game you guys  is he is still wearing the Hat now if  you don't know the storyline of this hat  it's a pretty good one in 1876 there was  an attempt by the current Hogwarts  caretaker his name was rancorous carp he  took it upon himself to try and get rid  of peeves now I'm not gonna spoil it  I'll let you go and read the whole story  for yourself I've actually talked about  it in a previous video but no surprise  it did not work they did not get peeves  to leave the castle it was a  catastrophic event and it actually took  the headmistry supraxia mole bargaining  with peeves to calm everything down and  one of his requirements for him to give  in and surrender is he wanted a new hat  made by Madame bonable of Paris and so I  think this is that very same hat right  here we saw him wearing it earlier in  the first trailer we see him wearing it  here again I expect he'll be wearing it  throughout the entire game